[Music]
after decades of western intervention
war and instability a year after the
taliban took over
more and more of afghanistan's children
are going to bed hungry every day
it is a fact that misery and poverty is
increasing in our country day by day the
higher the poverty rates the more
malnutrition cases there are
malnutrition in the impoverished nation
was always a problem
since the u.s pullout international
humanitarian aid has dried up
unicef estimates the number of
malnourished afghan children has doubled
in the past year
we are so upset we feel depressed my
husband even said he wants to go to iran
to look for work because he feels
ashamed that he can't afford to buy him
medicine or milk he said my son is dying
in front of my eyes but i am not capable
of doing anything
hardships for some of the most
vulnerable afghans began even before
they were born
i didn't have enough to eat during
pregnancy i couldn't buy the medicines i
needed that is why my child is now
malnourished and i have no money to
treat my child in a better way
he hasn't been well since he was born
he's always sick we do not have enough
money to buy him medicines and treat him
properly somewhere better
following what amounted to a defeat at
the hands of the taliban world powers
introduced punitive policies towards the
new government isolating afghanistan
financially crippling its economy and
weakening the people
the world afghan say has turned its back
on the most vulnerable victims of
conflict
some
too weak to keep crying for help
zayn basravi al jazeera